bonjour lui qui à travers merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france selon le secrétaire général
du syndicat alliance stanislas godon le
manifestant aurait dit aux policiers qui
le frappe
samedi je cite j'ai le sida tu vas
crever est ce que vous confirmez ses
propos oui je confirme en tous points
ses propos et il est effectivement un
propos très important de le remettre
dans leur contexte
ces propos sont sont la finalité est
bien d'une série de violences qui a
réalisé cette même personne contre
plusieurs policiers premièrement en
jetant divers projectiles et notamment
une bouteille en verre qui va éclater
sur un des collègues qui étaient dans le
dispositif
puis une seconde fois eh bien il va tout
simplement venir au contact des
policiers les frapper par derrière dans
le dos sur la tête alors même que ses
collègues étaient affairés à interpeller
une personne qui d'ailleurs avec les
coups qu'ils vont prendre bien vont
surtout penser à se protéger
ça va faire fuir d'ailleurs l'une des
personnes interpellées
et enfin cette même personne et bien
qu'ils commettaient ces exactions
parfaitement reconnue et bien est elle
même à son tour subi les assauts des des
policiers et va être effectivement
plaqué au sol et alors qu'un policier
est bien qui va s'approcher de lui pour
voir un petit peu ce qu'il a au niveau
du cuir chevelu parce qu'il y avait une
plaie saignante donc alors alliée à la
base pour l'aider et bien va prendre
trois crachats succès successifs
notamment avec du sang est effectivement
à l'occasion du 2ème crachats et bien il
va dire la phrase que vous avez
effectivement évoqué à savoir j'ai le
sida tu vas crever malgré les propos que
vous rapportez ici les propos du
manifestants sont avérées si les
exactions que vous venez de décrire son
sont avérées également malgré tout cela
est ce que ça justifie une telle
violence de la part du policier en
question
c'est pas de la violence monsieur je
crois que vous vous trompez sur le mot
que vous employez les policiers comme
les gendarmes à partir du moment où vous
avez un attroupement et qu'il ne s'agit
plus d'une manifestation mais bel et
bien d'un attroupement dans lequel il y
a eu des sommations et bien doivent
obtempéré notamment à la charge des
policiers
doivent simplement et bien s'écarter ou
déguerpir de l'endroit dans lequel ils
commettent leur violence or là ce n'est
pas le cas ils sont venus à plusieurs à
la charge plusieurs reprises jusqu'à ce
que cette personne effectivement qui
était au sol et bien et cracher une
première fois du sang visage de mon
collègue une deuxième fois avant même
qu'ils se racle la gorge et qu'il donne
cette phrase assassine que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure eh bien il lui a
été porté à ce qu'on appelle un coup
porté un atemi pour faire diversion et
d'ailleurs le crachat n'a pas atteint sa
cible une seconde fois au niveau du
visage
mais sur la manche donc on avait
quelqu'un de fou particulièrement
effectivement excité et qui
effectivement tentait est bien de se
soustraire à sa façon et de ne pas
obtempérer aux policiers et c'est ce
n'est pas de la violence comme comme
vous dites
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que c'est alors
alors c'est la légitime la justice qu'il
doit qui doit l'évoquer et qui doit qui
doit insister à partir du moment où les
policiers interviennent dans un contexte
d'attroupement si effectivement usage de
la force qui est autorisé par la police
est disproportionnée et bien c'est ni
vous ni moi ni twitter ni facebook qui
vont l'établir il va y avoir forcément
une enquête préliminaire voir une
instruction est bien qui va mener
pourquoi pas mais je n'y crois pas dans
ce cadre là et bien à un procès ou alors
les collègues en répondront devant un
conseil de discipline dont il n'y a pas
150 mille façons il ya simplement et
bien des éléments à charge et à décharge
dans une enquête ou administratives ou
judiciaires et bien qui peut mener à ce
que l'on dise que ce sont des violences
policières pour l'instant celle usage de
la force par des policiers
rien ne dit qu'elles étaient
disproportionnés au moment où on parle
cet incident est ce qu'il n'est pas à
augmenter
de nature à augmenter les tensions qui
sont déjà très vive avec les
manifestants une semaine après la
conférence de presse du ministre de
l'intérieur qui demande à la police plus
d'éthique la problématique des tensions
les pas d'aujourd'hui depuis 2007 on a
vu des groupes extrêmement radicaux et
bien égayer les différents les
différentes manifestations qui sont
déroulées que ce soit à l'occasion de la
loi elle comrie la loi travail que ce
soit dans le cadre des gilet jaune et
puis plus récemment dans le cas de ai
bien de certaines manifestations liées à
la réforme des retraites
voilà le vrai débat c'est qu'il y a une
vraie montée de violence que ce soit par
le biais ou de black blocks ou deux
personnes qui sont radicalisées ou des
personnes et biens qui simplement
viennent piller certains magasins qui
vient de se faire plaisir et c'est par
c'est ça qui était extrêmement difficile
à endiguer et c'est ça eh bien ces
phénomènes la de bande ou pas d'ailleurs
que les policiers essaient d'enrayer
avec des techniques qui sont
effectivement extrêmement précises qui
sont pour le moment est clairement
techniquement juridiquement adapté sauf
si on nous dit le contraire en tout cas
elles sont encore enseignée dans les
écoles mais en tout cas ce qui est
embêtant c'est qu'il y à de nombreux
propos depuis quelques semaines qui dit
ben voilà que la police ne doit plus
utiliser les lacrymogènes
elle doit plus utiliser la matraque
télescopique elle ne doit plus utilisé
l'étranglement
elle ne doit plus utiliser le placage
ventrale un moment il faut bien qu'il
nous reste des techniques pour
interpeller les gens violents
on va pas finir en tutu avec une fleur à
la main pour interpeller des gens qui
s'en prennent à nos collègues qui n'ont
qu'une envie de blesser gravement voire
de tuer nos de la fin merci beaucoup
lake travers d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
je rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national ile-de-france du syndicat à
police alliance